elle essaye de tenir un rythme d'environ
9 permanences itinérantes par mois mais
une fois n'est pas coutume ce matin il
n'y avait personne pour rencontrer et
béatrice piron à l'hôtel de ville de
villepreux lé rendez vous programmé ses
tantes annulé en dernière minute
en général j'ai deux ou trois rendez
vous parlera par séance alors ça semble
s'estomper un petit peu parce qu'il y
avait au départ beaucoup d'attentes donc
j'avais eu jusqu'à quatre rendez vous
plus qu'on me demande au mois de
septembre
et là lorsque ce sont les vacances ou
pas ça commence à se calmer un petit peu
présentes à l'assemblée nationale du
mardi au jeudi la députée a bloqué sur
son agenda les lundi et vendredi pour
rencontrer la population
elle va se rendre ainsi régulièrement
dans douze des treize communes de la
circonscription
seule la ville du chesnay a refusé
d'accueillir la parlementaire faute de
salle disponible
ces moments de discussions permettent à
l'élu de rester connectés avec son
territoire ça me permet de découvrir et
de mieux appréhender du mes dossiers au
lieu d'être purement législatif jeu
je prends connaissance de faits
particuliers de dossiers particuliers ça
permet aussi de rentrer en contact avec
des élus ou des administrations du
département les sujets abordés lors des
permanences itinérantes sont variés des
difficultés avec l'administration aux
problèmes routiers
une démarche de rencontre qui plaît aux
villes provient même s'il regrette de ne
pas avoir été mise au courant de la
venue de leur député
non je pense à très bien sûr qu'elle
aille au contact des gens tu très
importante parce que franchement on peut
on peut les rencontrer on peut leur
parler
ah je la trouve excellente à partir du
moment où on nous prévient mais là on
n'a pas été prévenu non ne savait pas il
n'ya pas d'affichés rien
prochaines permanences itinérantes le 3
novembre à la mairie des
clayes-sous-bois lé rencontre avec l'élu
se font uniquement sur rendez vous